ÇDiese Claire Zachanassian ist ja
auch eine hartherzige Person,
hat sieben EhemŠnner hinter
sich, ist ein Ersatzteillager.È
ÇAcht.È
ÇAcht. Also den Achten
nimmt sie...È
ÇNeun.È
ÇAlso egal, Philipp.
Sei nicht so kleinkariert.È
ÇOkay.È
ÇEin Jahrhundert DŸrrenmatt.
Wir haben uns darauf geeinigt,
dass wir Ÿber den ÜBesuch
der alten DameÝ sprechenÝ.
Claire Zachanassian kommt nach
langen, langen Jahren
in ihr Heimatdorf GŸllen zurŸck,
und zwar will sie sich an Alfred Ill rŠchen,
mit dem sie einst ein VerhŠltnis hatte,
der sie geschwŠngert hat
und dann aber verstossen hat.
Sie ist weggegangen.
Sie hat im Bordell gearbeitet. Sie hat
sieben reiche, acht reiche EhemŠnner geheiratet,
ist stinkreich, kommt jetzt
zurŸck in die Stadt und sagt:
Wenn ihr mir diesen Alfred Ill um die
Ecke bringt, spende ich eine Milliarde.
Ich nehme jetzt mal
deine Kritik vorweg.È
ÇBin ich so durchschaubar?È
ÇPhilipp wird jetzt sagen,
es ist ein bissel altertŸmlich.È
ÇBissel wŸrde ich sicher nicht sagen.È
ÇNa, wie findest du es denn?È
ÇIch glaube, es ist ein Zeichen
fŸr die QualitŠt des Buches,
dass ich es tatsŠchlich total
anders fand als frŸher.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Zeichen dafŸr,
dass das Buch verschieden gesehen werden kann.
Und das ist schon mal gut.
Ich finde, wenn man sich das
mal wirklich Ÿberlegt,
šffnet das eine ganz neue,
interessante Perspektive, zu sagen:
Wer ist hier eigentlich
fŸr was verantwortlich?
Ich finde den Aspekt interessant,
den Ill mehrfach ausspricht,
nŠmlich dass Claire nur deswegen dieses Leben
in unglaublich viel Geld und Luxus hat,
weil sie die Entscheidung getroffen hat,
mit der er auch zu tun hat.
Er sagt ja, ich habe dich zu
dem gemacht, was du bist.È
ÇJa, aber unter welchen UmstŠnden?È
ÇNein aber Nicola, das
ist schon noch interessant.
Weil es berŸhrt die Frage von:
Wer ist eigentlich fŸr welche Entscheidung
wie verantwortlich? Weil wenn man
Rache Ÿben will oder Vergeltung,
dann schreibt man ja
klar die Schuld zu.È
ÇJa, aber das tut sie.È
ÇDas tut sie. Aber was
fŸr das StŸck spricht, ist,
dass man als Leser ihr das
ja nicht wirklich abkauft.
Man entwickelt ja eine Distanz
zu allen Figuren. Das ist eine QualitŠt.È
ÇDa sind wir uns einig.
Das ist eine grosse QualitŠt.
Was mir aber besonders gut gefŠllt,
ist diese geheuchelte SolidaritŠt der Dšrfler.
die dann alle schon anfangen,
sich neue Sachen zu kaufen
und in Luxus zu schwelgen,
obwohl noch gar nichts passiert ist.
Und gleichzeitig aber Ill gegenŸber
zu heucheln, wir stehen auf deiner Seite,
wir sind fŸr dich da, wenn du uns
brauchst. Das finde ich grossartig gemacht.È
ÇDa habe ich gemerkt,
dass DŸrrenmatt kein …konom ist.
Es reicht aus, wenn die Leute sich
die Sachen kaufen,
damit die Wirtschaft wieder anspringt.È
ÇAber es geht ja nicht um die Wirtschaft.È
ÇDoch, es geht ja um Wohlstand fŸr GŸllen.È
ÇMich hat es stark an eine
antike Tragšdie erinnert,
weil es sehr typenhafte Figuren sind.
Es wird Ÿberhaupt viel expliziert.È
ÇEs ist ja nicht umsonst so, dass dieses
TheaterstŸck immer noch SchullektŸre ist.
Diese ganzen Leitmotive, die da aufploppen,
sind einfach in dem Sinne
zeitlos, fŸr eine
bestimmte Altersgruppe.È
ÇAber was heisst es auch?
Dass man offenbar immer noch
zurŸckgreifen muss auf diesen Text,
weil das eine Art von Literatur ist,
die offenbar nicht mehr produziert wird,
weil niemand offenbar beschŠftigt sich
mehr in dieser Form mit diesen Fragen.È